welcome back to new rockstars I'm Sam
Bash and I'm here today to break down
one of the many trailers we witnessed
during the big game or more properly
named I was tasked with finding every
hint and hidden treasure I could
possibly find in the new dress world
fallen Kingdom a trailer oh boy it was a
treat right off the bat there are so
many homage as to other Jurassic Park
films but let's not get ahead of
ourselves here here's your quick spoiler
warning for the Jurassic Park franchise
Jurassic world one and the new one and
dinosaurs in general they're really cool
I don't want to spoil you on anything
let's get started
[Music]
universals leaning into its scarier
roots love the music box recreation of
the Jurassic Park theme but that's not
the only throwback in this scene for
example the opening shot of the girl
crying shaking in her bed out of fear
this actually is probably a nod to
children being a big part of the
Jurassic Park franchise from Lex and Tim
and Jurassic Park to Kelly and lost
world my favorite out of the franchise
to Zack in gray in Jurassic world
I'm skipping that kid who collected
t-rex be in Jurassic 3 don't you get it
you don't know but moving on a kid being
afraid in bed in a Jurassic Park film is
not new for this series this actually
looks like somewhat of a recreation of
when the t-rex snuck into the base camp
during lost world almost a total
recreation with his mouth you know
hovering over the child how the t-rex
was able to sneak into that camp and no
one besides a few people woke up is
literally beyond me but also also there
is another time a dino woke somebody up
had to use that somewhere moving on
sorry got off-track for just a second
but also pay attention here to the
shadow being cast in the wall very scary
indeed and a very cool nod to this
intimating shadow from Jurassic Park
that scene will never not freak me out
even lining up with another figure in
the room specifically that fake horse
kind of like how it lined up with the
mural of the Velociraptor next you
probably noticed right off the bat the
infamous toe tap from the first drastic
park is when the velociraptors are
hunting the children in the parks
kitchen but look a little closer this
beast is actually a lot different from a
Raptor but there are some similar
qualities could this be another
indominus rex like the genetically
engineered dino from jurassic world or
is this something new
stay tuned I've got some theories also
it had been announced that a chunk of
this movie would take place off Island
much like in lost world so this whole
scene might be in San Diego or some
other city probably not San Diego
there's going to be a lot of
similarities to lost world so get ready
I'm excited roll the next clip do you
remember the first time you saw
that dinosaur thank you we don't really
believe it it's like
America here we open up on a viral
marketing clip we saw a few months back
of a baby version of blue the
Velociraptor from Jurassic world
imprinting on oh and Chris Pratt's
character during this we're Claire Bryce
Dallas Howard character doing some vo
talking about the magic of seeing a
dinosaur for the first time which is
pretty accurate to how we all felt
watching the first Jurassic Park movie
when the Brachiosaurus walked in the
frame heck we even get a recreation of
that famous pan up shot from the first
film to the Apatosaurus walking through
the wreckage of Jurassic world I'm not
sure if this is a Brachiosaurus based on
the list of dressing world dinos but hey
let me know if I'm mixing up my dinos in
the comments down below I'm not I did my
research really quick we're gonna back
it up just a little bit we see the
islands volcano erupting which we saw in
the first trailer as well very scary
also all the dinos fleeing for their
lives is very sad right here though I
believe we see these flying boys those
beetle vana Dawn's the flying beasts
from Jurassic world and oh boy they're
very scary we also get a close-up of our
new character who on IMDB has been
listed as Franklin and while frankly his
screaming does annoy the bejesus out of
me I do think I have somewhat of an idea
what his role will be in all of this he
does serve a purpose but more on that
soon then we get a shot of a dino being
airlifted off the island and from what
I've been able to gather based on the
list that I've combed over over and over
again this looks to either be a Baryonyx
one of the main bad dinosaurs of the
movie or a Sukkah - but this is pretty
hard to tell since it's so far away
however pay attention to the background
of the shot get some important stuffs
happening notice the lava pouring down
the cliffside over to the right of the
screen and our main two characters right
here our totally drenched head-to-toe
I'm guessing this follows the
death-defying plunge off the cliff in
the gyrosphere just an observation
that'd be cool next clip something's
coming
is it your ex is the t-rex
right off the bat d-27 what could that
tag mean I'm guessing it has to be like
a tracker similar to the one that the
indominus rex dug out of itself in
Jurassic world but what does this code
mean easy guys with the D probably for
Dino or possibly Dino variant as there
are some genetic hybrids running around
this island point seven however could
mean a couple different things either
the twenty-seventh species of Dino on
the island which doesn't quite make
sense since no website for Jurassic
world or fallen Kingdom shows that many
Dino species possibly this is the 27th
genetic experiment meaning that there
are more hybrids running around the
island or fun option this is the 27th of
this new hybrid meaning that there are a
whole bunch of these monsters who knows
maybe I don't know pray also pay
attention to where Franklin is when the
scene begins he looks up from the screen
and then he's standing over by the
wrecked computer consoles in this bunker
it looks like my guess he is the techie
that every good team needs to help them
hack their way to victory hooray again
also I'm glad the t-rex is getting more
love in this movie than in Jurassic
world but how in the world would you fit
it down there like he's it that that
thing has to be ally you boy a little
skinny boy to fit in there this could
possibly be the Baryonyx the breed I
mentioned earlier or possibly a new
hybrid hmm I know there are some
similarities from the opening shot with
that evil Dino in this one but there are
linked do seem to be considerably
different so I'm gonna say there are two
different die notes also is that thing
lava proof no right doesn't make any
sense the dinosaur wouldn't do that but
it looks like it just gets nicked by it
who knows next clip boo come with me
Jurassic world
the island
easy girl all of that is in the past
my dad I get kid
well a stuff happens here it's a meaty
clip let's sink our teeth into it Wiggly
laughs the back we see this scene once
again of most likely Owen and blues
reconnecting scene on the island Blue
has been running free for a while will
she come with Owen off the island save
her own life
who knows also pay attention to that
Flint Jeep back there could that
possibly be the Jeep that fell off the
cliff in the first Jurassic Park film
who knows that big tree behind it does
sure look familiar but a it's too early
to tell and we see the same shot of
Clair and Franklin flying off the cliff
scream and their heads off and then
these trains just keep on shooting
themselves in the foot plot wise and the
first trailer we get a glimpse of the
metric Antho soros or the car no Thoris
and then boom is taken out by the T to
the Rex and now we get confirmation that
Owen does survive getting engulfed in an
ash cloud from the first trailer
we then hear Eli mills Rafe smalls
character saying that Jurassic world is
a thing of the past hinting to possibly
yet again making a new park on the
mainland or instead possibly using the
dinos in other fields besides
entertainment Jurassic world director
Colin Trevorrow stated during the
release of his film that follow-up films
could play with the idea these dinos
used in agriculture medicine or most
likely war which was a big sell for
Vincent d'Onofrio's character in
Jurassic world
Eli Mills could be referring to any of
these options and there are some hints
to them later but we'll get to that soon
he didn't see a large syringe moving
blood down where's it goin and we see a
shot of Daniella Pineda's character who
is yet to be named on IMDB looking to be
operating on blue not sure what could
have happened who or possibly blue was
injured during the eruption maybe she
was shot but this does feel like a nice
throwback to win the team in lost world
had to operate on the baby t-rex freakin
loved that scene also shout out to the
team behind Jurassic world fallen
Kingdom love the use of practical
effects it's amazing also pay attention
to when Eli says all of that is in the
past and then boom we see the same show
the t-rex taking down the metric in
thesaurus or the car no Thoris I'm gonna
say both to cover my bases you can argue
about it in the comments down below I
know it looks like the car no tourists
carnal Thoris but the website for this
movie doesn't list that species but
anyway I wanted to point out that this
is a nod to that awesome final t-rex
shot from Jurassic Park when you scream
and after taking down all the
velociraptors here's a clip in case you
forgot
also love the detail of the scars from
the velociraptor fight from Jurassic
Park so cool
we then get our cast running away from
explosions caused by the lava making its
way through their camp hitting barrels
of fuel I'm guessing Claire is about to
do a jump possibly with a car and then
there's this awesome shot of Owen
jumping out of his way of a bound up
t-rex hmm
gives me goose bumps just looking at it
by the way that looks far too small of a
little container to house a t-rex and
why in the world would only need to
crawl through there to get anywhere but
I mean it's still cool but why just go
go outside I don't know at least the
t-rex is getting off the island and
we'll hopefully find a nice family to
adopt it next clip
I want to show you the future
this might actually be the first
introduction in the movie of our new
hybrid dinosaur which in this clip here
with Toby Jones officially reveals its
name the Indo Raptor that name had been
teased for a while but now it's official
in its freaky also check out those codes
behind Toby Jones those would be
shorthand names for the British Pound up
top than the euro in the Hong Kong
dollar than Japanese yen and then the
Singapore dollar meaning that these
people are gathered to bid on the
dinosaurs rescued from the island and my
guess is that the endure after isn't the
only Dino up for bid
we then see Owen Claire and the young
girl from earlier who look to be spying
on the bidding going on for the Indo
Raptor again I say this is a reveal
scene because our main casting surprised
to see it to discover it and it's being
rolled out in a cage on display for a
big reveal that's how it works people in
the next scene it looks like there's a
little odd as to how freaking terrifying
this interrupter actually is check out
the feet of this beast look at where
they're at in this room and look right
there as it steps down on some toys I'm
saying in that little brown toy right
there is either a Brachiosaurus or the
Apatosaurus the one in the movie or
possibly the t-rex mainly because of the
symbolism of this monster stepping on a
fan favorite killer we then get a save
from blue so yeah she most likely made
it off the island but pay attention here
check out the underside of the Indo
Raptors tail it almost has like a dark
blue coloration to it remember any other
dinos with a blue coloration that's
right a blue that was an easy one kids
we had fun there so maybe the scientists
use blues DNA to help engineer the in
director which could rightly piss off
our main characters enough for them to
step it up and protect the dinosaurs the
next shot we see Claire with a gun
aiming it somewhere towards the inside
of that young girl's house most likely
because it's the only house we've seen
in this film so far and the coloration
of the roof looks like the same
coloration outside the girls bedroom and
it's raining in both shots so these are
probably connected if you try to take
down the endo Raptor possibly you let me
know and then my favorite part we get a
few scenes of the Dinos going crazy
first up the t-rex looking at a
helicopter really hope we see the t-rex
take it down unless it's our main
characters let's still may be they
survived it would just be cool
we didn't see a jailbreak of sorts with
dinos running free and taking out the
guards and a screaming of Baryonyx or a
suku - probably go
to eat that dude let's be honest and a
Toronto Don taking a man away into the
clouds to have it most likely can't wait
for these diners to roam free in this
forest facility I'm guessing based on
the pine trees below the Toronto Don
maybe they're in Montana it would be a
good place to take dinos there's a lot
of space on that happy note let's watch
the end of this trailer do you need to
get us out of here
last shot I had to save it for you guys
I'm guessing this is the facility where
all the diners are being kept after
their you know shepherded off the island
and the home of that little girl is very
close to here since she's with the two
main characters we get this cheap jump
scare with the Dino killing lagarde but
it does look to be the Indo Raptor based
on the arm length that's my guess at
least and there you have it folks all
the Easter eggs the hidden references I
could find in the big game Jurassic
world fallen Kingdom trailer I hope you
enjoyed let me know your favorite Easter
eggs or the ones I missed in the
comments down below or on twitter at
only stupid answers but you ain't got
the valves from stupid there you go make
sure you like comment share and
subscribe and check out all of our other
breakdowns for the big game trailers all
the new trailers coming out I'm also
doing an MCU rewatch series which is a
bunch of fun and we do a new rockstars
new segment every week there's so much
concert for you guys it's like Christmas
I'm Sam basher again and I'll see it
next time